When Zhou Xiaoxuan posted on China’s social
network Weibo last summer, her accusation
hit like a bombshell.
She said she had been sexually harassed four
years ago by a famous TV anchor.
Her post was quickly
censored but it was already too late.
Her story had already been shared widely.
A lot of women who reposted this article wrote
that it reminded them of their own experiences.
I felt very sad, but was also moved.
In 2014 Zhou, then a drama student, had been
interning at China’s state broadcaster CCTV.
One day she was asked to come to the dressing
room of popular show host Zhu Jun.
It is there she says he forcibly tried
to kiss and grope her.
She managed to escape.
At first I didn’t want anybody to know I’d
been molested.
I felt this was embarrassing, humiliating.
And I also thought that if anybody knew about
this story, none of the CCTV employees would
take my side.
They
would stand with him.
The anchor has denied the accusations and
filed a lawsuit against her, He’s demanded
the equivalent of 85.000 euros for damaging
his reputation.
Zhou Xiaoxuan is feeling the pressure.
I feel like a vessel that quickly fills up
with all kinds of emotions.
Most of the time I am so busy that I manage
to keep it together.
But sometimes you can’t suppress these feelings
anymore and that’s when I
break down.
Zhou has become a leading voice of China’s
small but persistent MeToo-Movement.
Many women have sought her advice.
She has offered to help some of them with
filing complaints at the police.
But she says what
China really needs is an open discussion about
the issue.
When it becomes known that a woman has been
assaulted, people will say she has been “stained“.
Even the media use this word.
The woman is considered dirty.
In the eyes of the public, women have to be
pure and a
woman who has been sexually harrassed is suddenly
seen as a strange, sick person.
As for Zhou Xiaoxuan – she’s fighting
back.
After the presenter Zhu sued her for defamation,
she’s bringing her own case to court.
She’s demanding compensation for sexual
harassment.